des unités de quatre pays membres de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective se retrouvent ici au
kirghizstan pour des manoeuvres pour
simuler l'incursion de groupes armés
illégaux sur le territoire de l'un de
ces pays voyons voir comment ça se passe
[Musique]
plus de mille soldats mais également 150
équipements militaires ont participé par
milieu des chars des véhicules de
transport de troupes des véhicules
blindés de type tigre ou encore des
pièces d'artillerie des hélicoptères ou
encore des avions de chasse à propos de
l'hélicoptère le pilote d'un des deux
appareils qui passe juste derrière moi
vous expliquer le rôle dans ces
exercices
dans le cadre des exercices conjoints
hrubesch 2021 des équipages
d'hélicoptères stationné sur la base
aérienne de kant ont détruit par le feu
une cible ennemie et procéder au
débarquement de commandos tactique
appartenant aux forces spéciales de la
russie et du kirghizistan la difficulté
est liée à l'altitude de 1700 mètres au
dessus du niveau de la mer au relief
montagneux et au changement constant du
vent c'est très dangereux dans un
premier temps il s'agit d'identifier la
menace la localiser puis bombardé la
position comme c'est le cas en ce moment
puis enfin empêcher tout repli de
l'adversaire
le but de ces manoeuvres est simple
favoriser la coopération et
l'interopérabilité entre les unités de
ces différents pays et ce dans le
contexte très particulier de l'asie
centrale en ce moment le contexte du
changement de pouvoir en afghanistan
en ce moment le monde entier préoccupés
par l'évolution future de la situation
en afghanistan même et autour du pays
grâce aux dons nous savons tous qu'il y
a des états membres de notre
organisation qui ont des frontières
communes avec l'afghanistan je crois que
notre tâche consiste à être prêts à
toute évolution de la situation est donc
le but d exercice a été défini nous
sommes principalement orientée sur la
lutte contre la menace terroriste
nous n'avons jamais oublié qu'un tel
problème existait à la frontière entre
nos pays et l'afghanistan pour le moment
la situation y est disons instable
on l'aura compris ces exercices cherche
à faire passer un message aux groupes
islamistes qui seraient tenté de
déborder
depuis l'afghanistan tout proche et le
message est le suivant toutes tentatives
d'agressions de menaces à la sécurité
d'un des pays membres de l'organisation
du traité de sécurité collective sera
durement réprimées